A "Big Bang Theory" star is stepping into
an iconic sitcom role, and she has a big
robe to fill. But what happened to
the original "Night Court" judge?
The brand new "Night Court" is a sequel series to
the classic sitcom that premiered back in 1984,
and ran until 1992, with 193 episodes.
Both "Night Court" series take place
in a courtroom setting in New York City,
though what makes this premise different is
that "Night Court," as the name implies,
covers the graveyard shift. This means
that the stories and cases are usually zany
misadventures featuring colorful characters.
Of course, it takes somebody special
to preside over such a courtroom,
and the new "Night Court" lets Judge
Abby Stone, played by Melissa Rauch,
have a tremendous amount of fun, despite
the lofty and often humorless role.
Fans of the original "Night Court" will remember
the judge who held sway in that courtroom,
Harry Anderson's Judge Harry Stone. Harry
wound up presiding over the original "Night
Court" because the Mayor was simply too busy
and overwhelmed doling out positions within
the government, and Harry happened to be
one of the few people to answer his phone.
Harry soon found himself working the night
shift courtroom in Manhattan — though on
account of his young age and unique outlook
on life, his rulings were usually much more
personable and understanding than what many may
experience when coming face-to-face with a judge.
The new "Night Court," with Judge Abby Stone
presiding, has already established that Abby
is Harry's daughter, and in one of her first
interactions with series veteran Dan Fielding,
played by John Larroquette, the two discuss Harry.
Dan was the prosecutor in the original "Night
Court," meaning that he's exceptionally familiar
with Harry, as the two had something
of a friendly antagonism. However,
Dan mentions that although Harry and himself
hadn't been close in quite some time,
he offers condolences on Harry's
passing, which is kept vague.
"I was sorry to hear about your father.
We had lost touch over the
years, but he was a great guy."
Actor Harry Anderson was beloved on the original
"Night Court" and other famous shows like
"Cheers," and his death in 2018 at the age of 65
due to a stroke was a real loss for the television
landscape. The new "Night Court" revival
decided that instead of recasting the role,
they instead would reflect real life with an
off-screen death. This has not been lost on
those who remember the original show, with quite
a few expressing their thoughts on social media.
On Reddit, fans tried to place
some of the seemingly random
items delivered to Judge Abby Stone's
office, with one viewer pointing out,
Another fan on Reddit brought up the rapid fire
nature of the jokes on this new "Night Court,"
and felt like if the show slowed down,
the laughs would be a bit more robust.
"Your past, your feelings, you've put your
whole life in a box and won't let anyone in."
"Wait, hold on a second. Am I in the box or am I
putting things in the box?"
"I kind of lost the thread."
The fan then mentioned that the late Harry
Anderson had great comedic timing, and added,
Still, it seems as if many still
fondly remember Judge Harry,
and are happy to see him
referenced in the new show.